la région de barbout
objectif tenter de reprendre mètre carré
par mètre carré Horus
pendant des semaines ici la
contre-offensive ukrainienne semble être
stagner
j'ai l'impression que nous avons
commencé à faire mieux maintenant et que
les Russes se sont calmées du moins sur
notre partie du front
les Ukrainiens justifient l'absence de
succès par les mines qui ralentissent
les avancées mais ici les canons sont
très loin d'être sophistiqués
en utilisant de vieilles armes
soviétiques et les missiles sont
également vieux en ce sens l'Occident ne
nous a pas aidés
pendant ce temps Europe et États-Unis se
mobilisent pour apporter plus d'aide à
l'Ukraine à Bruxelles la Commission
propose une enveloppe de 20 milliards
d'euros sur quatre ans pour soutenir la
défense ukrainienne Washington de son
côté a débloqué une nouvelle aide de 800
millions de dollars il y a quelques
jours elle inclut des obusiers des
véhicules de combat et de transport de
troupes mais aussi des armes à
sous-munition des armes que Kiev
commence à utiliser malgré leur aspect
controversé
de manière très efficace
et ces armes ont en fait un impact sur
la défense russe ainsi que sur les
manœuvres Russes
pendant ce temps démonstration de force
des Russes un exercice naval mené en mer
Noire et dont le ministère de la Défense
présente des images Moscou veut empêcher
les navires notamment se transportant du
blé de se rendre dans la zone l'armée
russe a par ailleurs visé un terminal
serré allié dans le port d'eau des
saints ce vendredi